so in some sense
Mojo could be seen as python 4.0
I would not say that I think that would
drive a lot of people really crazy
because of the PTSD of the 3.02 I'm
willing to annoy people about emacs
versus Bim or without tax versus spaces
that's that one I don't know that might
be a little bit far even for me like my
my skin may not be that thick but the
point is the step to being a superset
and allowing all these capabilities I
think is the evolution of a language it
feels like an evolution of a language
so he he's interested by the ideas that
you're playing with but also concerned
about the fragmentation so how what are
the ideas you've learned what are you
thinking about how do we avoid
fragmenting the community where the the
pythonistas and uh
uh I don't know what to call the Mojo
people uh magicians The Magicians yeah I
like it uh can coexist happily and and
share a code and basically just have
these big code bases that are using uh C
Python and more and more moving towards
Mojo well so again these are lessons I
learned from Swift and and here we Face
very similar problems right and Swift
you have Objective C super Dynamic uh
they're very different syntax right but
you're talking to people who have large
scale code bases I mean Apple's got the
biggest largest scale code base of
objective c code right and so you know
none of the companies none of the iOS
developers none of the other developers
want to rewrite everything all at once
and so you want to be able to adopt
things piece at a time and so a thing
that I found that worked very well in
the Swift Community was saying okay cool
and this is when switch was very young
as you say okay you have a million line
of Code objective-c app
don't rewrite it all but when you
implement a new feature go Implement
that new class
using Swift right and so now this turns
out is a very wonderful thing for an app
developer
but it's a huge challenge for this
compiler team and the systems people
that are implementing this right and
this comes back to what is this
trade-off between doing the hard thing
that enables scale versus doing the
theoretically pure and ideal thing right
and so Swift adopted and built a lot of
different Machinery to deeply integrate
with the objective runtime and we're
doing the same thing with python right
now what what happened in the case of
Swift is that
Swift as the language got more and more
and more mature over time right and
incidentally Mojo is a much simpler
language than Swift in many ways and so
I think that Mojo will develop way
faster than Swift for a variety of
reasons but as the language gets more
mature in parallel with that you have
new people starting new projects
right and so if when the language is
mature and somebody's starting a new
project that's when they say okay cool
I'm not dealing with a million lines of
code I'll just start and use the new
thing for my whole stack now the problem
is again you come back to work
communities and we're
people that work together you build new
subsystem or a new feature a new thing
in Swift or you build a new thing in
Mojo
then you want to be end up being used on
the other side
right and so then you need to work on
integration back the other way
and so it's not just Mojo talking python
it's also python talking to Mojo right
and so what I would love to see I don't
want to see this next month right but
what I want to see over the course of
time is I would love to see people that
are building these packages like you
know numpy or uh you know tensorflow or
what you know these packages that are
half python half C plus plus
and if you say okay cool I want to get
out of this python C plus plus world
into a unified role and so I can move to
Mojo but I can't give up on my python
clients because they're like these
libraries get used by everybody and
they're not all going to switch ever all
you know all once and maybe never right
well so the way we should do that is we
should vend python interfaces to the
Mojo types
and that's what we did in Swift and
we're great I mean it was a huge
implementation challenge for the
compiler people right but um there's
only a dozen of those compiler people
and there are millions of users and so
it's a very expensive Capital intensive
like skill set intensive problem but
once you solve that problem it really
helps adoption it really helps the
community progressively adopt
Technologies and so I think that this
approach will work quite well with with
the Python and the Mojo world so for a
package ported to Mojo and then create a
python interface yep